if you had to give Laura some advice for
seasons coming what would it be
be strong don't let your family [ __ ]
your out anymore
keep your hair looking good keep the
sass I just be strong let's just keep
being badass front foot come on rezaian
he's in a world of heart with Stannis
isn't he and unappreciative boss keeping
your chasers gird your loins you're in
for a bumpy ride I would say to him
don't be so trusting and left the booze
mostly headaches from Cersei and
Margaery and she's eventually losing I
guess see the way he rode that boat at
the end of the series up I think it
bodes well for him to learn how to swim
me my advice to him would be just relax
don't push it you know take your time
try and judge the territory don't don't
don't give too much away acknowledged
just how brave he already is I don't
think it needs to get any braver stop
taking life so seriously it's not that
bad no he's been for a lot maybe
wouldn't say that a big bit insensitive
spend more time running he needs to man
up he needs to get fit stop getting
scared keep doing what you're doing
because he's always there any Barisan
should probably follow his current
agenda which is to be loyal support of
discretes stay your course don't get too
hot-headed make it a smile more
yes you do such serious things in there
were time it's just got a stick with it
I mean as a character da versus a you
know is his loyalties is one of his best
traits have a lot more confidence in
yourself
he's a good guy people like you Cersei
and Joffrey and you know Tywin they all
go to watch the backs science is coming
together maybe like goes with Kaylee
y'all right you know